Now, we're going to learn how to specify important parts of HTML and JavaScript,
and, in an incredible surprise move, we're going to do this specification
using regular expressions.
Just a quick reminder, an outline of the overall project,
we want to start with a web page and then break it down into important words.
Maybe the less than and the greater than sign used for the tag are important words,
the 1, the plus, and the 2, but we're largely ignoring this sort of white space
or these new line characters.
Then we want to take those words and diagram them into this cool tree-like structure.
Of course, this tree is growing upside down, but that won't be a problem at all.
Finally, we're going to interpret that tree to figure out what it means to get the result.